[Inaudible].
Nagorno-Karabakh is one of those regions that you didn't even know existed until
two weeks ago.
Suddenly it's now all over the media because it's the scene of the first open
war between two nations that we've seen in a long time.
[Inaudible].
You know, in visual politic, we often talk about asymmetric warfare gorillas,
or maybe civil Wars,
but it seemed that open Wars were kind of a thing of the past. However,
from Sunday, the 27th of September, 2020, until the time of making this video,
the war between Azerbaijan and Armenia has clocked up more than 6,000 deaths,
including about 50 civilians.
[Inaudible].
Of course those numbers could be even higher because at least for now,
the war is not over.
There is a real risk that we will end up seeing ethnic cleansing or even.
[Inaudible].
And for all this conflict is the issue of control of Nagorno-Karabakh.
We are talking about a region of 4,400 square kilometers with about 150,000
inhabitants. Officially this territory belongs to Azerbaijan,
but in reality, almost the entire population is ethnically Armenian.
Sadly,
this is not the first time that something like this has happened in this region,
the first war and the Garneau Karabakh broke out in the late 1980s and ended the
lives of more than 30,000 people,
as well as rendering 1 million people displaced from both Armenian and
Azerbaijani backgrounds since then minor skirmishes between the two armies have
been a regular occurrence. In fact, in 2016, there was another collage,
the left almost 200 soldiers dead from both sites and had 15 civilians.
[Inaudible].
We were talking about a conflict that goes back decades and in which the great
powers are unsure, which side to support for the moment.
The only country that has taken sides is Turkey,
which supports the Azeris on Friday. The 9th of October,
Russia saw Armenia and Azerbaijan done it with the objective of achieving a
ceasefire. But hours later,
the Azerbaijani guns were again bombing the capital of Nagorno-Karabakh a city
called [inaudible].
Many media sources are reporting this war as if it were an invasion by
Azerbaijan over Armenian territories. But the real story is much more complex.
What's one is right backhoe or the element.
It is very difficult to have an opinion in this case, but in this video,
we are going to outline at least the main issues, the height, the culture.
[Inaudible].
And I know what many of you are probably thinking,
this is not the first time we've talked about Nagorno-Karabakh on visual politic
in April of this year.
We told you how it looked like Armenia and Azerbaijan might be on the verge of
signing a peace agreement.
It was the Munich security conference where Azerbaijani president Elle hum,
Leo and Armenian prime minister nickel [inaudible] were discussing the matter in
the same room, but clearly we were rolling.
International politics is unpredictable and no one has a crystal ball.
In any case, it's important to recognize mistakes.
And it is precisely that reason that we have made this,
The question we are asking today is who is Russia going to support and who are
the United States and the European union going to support?
Why has this war broken out right now? What exactly is happening?
And a granola quarterback today, we're going to answer all those questions,
but first let's look at a little bit of history.
A story without heroes.
So at this point, I know what you're all wondering,
who are the good guys and this story and principle is easy to empathize with
Armenia.
The Armenians are one of the most abused peoples in history to give you an idea
during the first world war,
the ultimate empire killed more than 2 million Armenians. And even today,
Turkey refuses to acknowledge the Armenian genocide ever happened.
What's more Armenia as a democracy.
And an interesting side note was the first Christian country.
In history.
Can we say about Azerbaijan is a corrupt dictatorship with few rivals,
the classic case of a country with enormous gas reserves whose profits have gone
directly into the pockets of the ruling oats.
That's explains why the Azerbaijani dictator Ilham Alia has one of the world's
greatest fortunes.
The best thing we can say about this country is that it is one of the most
secular countries in the world.
However,
if you think that the Azerbaijanis are the villains and that the Armenians are
the avenging angels, I am sorry to say that you are wrong.
And this story there are simply no good guys. You see for centuries,
the Nagorno-Karabakh region was populated by both Armenian Christians and Azeri
Shiite Muslims. This is good firmed by numerous censuses from the 19th century.
That time with Armenia and Azerbaijan were part of the Russian empire. However,
in 1918, these two countries became independent and guess what happened next?
They went to war a war that ended with Russia at this time,
communist invading those two countries again.
So once more Armenians and those areas were forced to live together under the
protective mantle of the Soviet union.
Since.
The time of Stalin back in 1923,
Nagorno-Karabakh has belonged to the socialist Republic of Azerbaijan. Why?
Well, because that's the way Stalin wanted it.
I just tried to find anyone who would dare to oppose it.
[Inaudible].
Things changed in 1998. At that time,
Armenians living in the Garneau quarterback took advantage of the new political
freedoms that Mikhail Gorbachev had put in place to cast a vote in the regional
parliament,
a vote in which they asked that the region ceased to be parts of Azerbaijan and
become part of the Republic of Armenia and stent.
Armenians living in this area complained that the backhoe government did not
allow them to watch television or receive education in Armenian for their part.
The Azeris took to the streets to protest because they were not willing to give
up the region and the Armenians. And yet that the same,
that's how the Nagorno-Karabakh war broke out.
That did not end until 1994.
This war caused more than 30,000 casualties, including lots of civilians.
And it resulted in more than a million displaced people.
The $850,000 series we've been living in the region had to relocate to other
parts of Azerbaijan and the $250,000 millions living in Azerbaijan had to move
to Armenia. And other words, we are talking about a total ethnic cleansing,
but left indelible wounds.
[Inaudible].
You will see. So who won, who won the war? Well,
we could say that the winner was Armenia,
although Nagorno-Karabakh has officially a regional Azerbaijan. In fact,
we are talking about the so-called art SAC Republic,
a state where the police are Armenian.
The currency they use is Armenian and the official language is Armenian.
The place is so controlled by Armenia that two of the last Armenian presidents
were born and stood upon a character that is the capital of the art SAC
Republic. All of this helps explain why this war has never ended
Or a peace agreement. Only a ceasefire was agreed since 1992,
the O S C E or the organization for security and cooperation in Europe has been
trying to bring both sides together to negotiate a territorial agreements.
But this negotiating table is cheered by France, Russia and the United States.
All these countries have huge Armenian diasporas.
So Azerbaijan has never been willing to negotiate with them. Meanwhile, Armenia,
not only to kind of go into a counter back,
but also conquered all the territories that connect us region two.
Yeah.
That is about 20% of the territory of Azerbaijan.
And remember that there are more than 800,000 people who were expelled from the
land where they had always lived.
All this explains the auntie Armenian hatred professed in back who hate that
translates into statements.
Like this.
Well, main enemies are Armenians of the world and the hypocritical and corrupt
politicians under their control. It'll ham LEF as oppose yarn president.
And as you can imagine for the Elliot family,
hatred of Armenia has become a major political tool.
It is the perfect antagonist to justified all kinds of abuses of power.
To give you an idea.
People like Kim Kardashian are considered public enemies and Azerbaijan.
I don't know if you knew this,
but Kim Kardashian is of Armenian origin and for the [inaudible] narrative,
she is one more of the many Armenians who spread propaganda,
wherever they go consider that most of the Armenian population currently lives
outside the country.
There are more than 8 million Armenians living in countries like the United
States or Russia. And that's Armenian diaspora feeds Azerbaijan's persecution.
[inaudible] Because if you think that Armenia is willing to negotiate, boy,
Oh boy, are you wrong to date?
Armenia is only willing to maintain the status quo that has to keep its Republic
of oxide clean of Azeris also, and all the surrounding regions too. For example,
in 2007,
the foreign ministers of Armenia and Azerbaijan sat down to negotiate and
Madrid. This led to the so-called Madrid principle.
[Inaudible] principles say.
That Armenia should allow the return of the Azeris who were living in Nagorno.
And afterwards all the inhabitants of the region,
including the Azeris to hold a referendum on self-determination.
This referendum would be monitored by international security forces.
This would imply the Armenia would withdraw its troops.
And that is something that neither Yerevan nor the rest of the Armenian
diaspora,
except most significantly the Armenian association in the United States has
rejected these principles as undemocratic.
In other words, neither country is willing to give an inch to achieve peace.
And that is why to date no major power has decided to support either site.
So what has changed since then? Well, one thing that has changed is the economy
In 1994, Armenia and Azerbaijan were two equally poor countries.
We could say that they were in a kind of Mexican standoff,
not as both countries had similar amounts of power and decided to approve a
ceasefire since then Armenia's economy has grown at the same rate as the rest of
the countries in the region. Meanwhile,
Azerbaijan story has been completely different in 1999.
Azerbaijan discovered something that changed his economy forever deep beneath
the Caspian sea. A trillion cubic meters is waiting to be tapped.
We are talking about the shot in these guests fields in the Caspian sea,
one of the largest gas fuels in the world,
suddenly Azerbaijan's GDP skyrocketed take a look at this graph.
[Inaudible].
To date, Azerbaijan has almost quadrupled Armenia's GDP,
and all this wealth has been converted into an army.
Since Azerbaijan has become a guest power,
they have not stopped signing defense agreements with a whole host of countries.
And that includes Russia, Israel, and Turkey.
And at about that moment is when the powers and back who said Armenia.
Do you remember that ceasefire that we approved because of the Mexican standoff?
Well, you're going to find out what.
We meet.
Oh, Karabakh violence,
worse clashes in decades killed dozens as news from 2016. At that time,
the war lasted just five days and resulted in 200 casualties.
Despite the fact that Azerbaijan had more modern weapons,
the Armenians managed to hold them off.
Remember with the whole area is controlled by Armenian troops,
that these troops are very well.
[Inaudible].
Other words Azerbaijan wanted to prove it's a periodicity over Armenia and
discovered that war was simply not a matter of money and weaponry.
Just ask the Saudi Arabian army in Yemen. Once again,
it seemed there was a certain balance of power at play.
So now you might be thinking, so what has changed? Well,
listen up because to understand that we have to pack our bags and travel to a
completely.
Different country.
The awakening of the Ottoman giant 15th, 2016,
we'll be forever remembered as the date of the failed coup d'etat.
In Turkey.
We've it several times here.
On visual politic for Turkish president, everyone,
this coup was a golden opportunity. Traditionally,
the Turkish army had been mainly Kemalists. In other words,
they were in favor of a secular and Western Turkey. Edwin however,
argued for the opposite. Many define his ideology as new optimism.
That is a return to the Ottoman empire or resurgence of Turkish nationalism.
As you can imagine, in order to carry out such an expansionist policy,
it's essential to have the army on your site.
And that is why after the coup de top,
everyone changed the constitution and carried out policies.
Yes.
Ode again, purge is army and you disarray after failed coup.
And all this explains the turn that Turkish politics have taken since 2016,
to give you an idea. Turkey is going through a very significant economic crisis.
In 2013, the GDP was $951 billion.
Six years later in 2019, it is at 754 billion. However,
despite the fact that the Turkish economy is going from bad to worse,
everyone's army is present on all possible fronts. Take a look.
Right?
I present to you the doctrine of MAVA tan, the blue hormone,
you're likely to get tired of hearing. It mentioned in the coming months,
Turkey wants to control all the seas surrounding the Mediterranean seat,
the GNC and the black seat.
This explains why the Turks are so present in the Wars and Olympia and why they
have entered into confrontations with Greece.
But not only that Turkey is also interested in controlling the Persian Gulf and
the Caspian sea. And you'll probably be thinking,
why are they so interested in controlling the seas? Well, for two reasons,
on the one hand, pure nationalist rhetoric on the other hand,
energy and dependence until recently both the oil and gas consumed by Turkey
came from two suppliers, Russia and Iran,
both countries have been traditional antagonists.
However things started to change in 2019.
[Inaudible].
Turkey and Azerbaijan,
Mark completion of tan app pipeline to take gas to Europe.
Remember how I told you that Neil automatism as a form of ethno nationalism,
that is Turkish. Nationalism is not based on religion nor on a political system,
but on a common race and culture.
The Azeris are a Turkic people with very similar language, ethnicity,
and culture. And that's why both LEF and everyone get along so well.
And previous visual policy videos,
we told you about the Turkish military industry,
but has been revived thanks to air to war.
No Turkey has its own mess out of launches, laser weapons,
and even its own drones. For example, the [inaudible] is very well known. Well,
one of his biggest buyers is none other than Azerbaijan.
[Inaudible].
Turkey as a [inaudible] deepen defense industry cooperation with new bilateral
agreement.
This news headline is from May, 2020,
but this time the by Johnny army was already supplied with Turkish,
Russian and Israeli weapons. And this means one thing and the coop,
we can finally beat the Armenians. Not only did their dictator,
Elle Hom Ali I've think so, but so did the Azerbaijanis.
[Inaudible] protestors demand war after Armenia clashes.
Around this time,
some countries like Canada decided to stop adding fuel to the fire and bond on
sales to Azerbaijan. Meanwhile,
Ankara has been encouraging back here to give you an idea.
Turkish support of the Azerbaijani army is so evident.
They even on the website of the ministry of defense in Azerbaijan,
we find pictures like.
This.
But I know what many of you are thinking.
Turkey is not the only country that has sold arms to Azerbaijan.
So why is Turkey support so important and this war? Well, to understand this,
we have to go back even further and tight watch out because a spine movie is
about to start.
The impossible alliances.
Syria, 2012 Syrian rebels rise up against the dictator.
Alisando many asks the us to intervene at that time.
The president was Barack Obama.
Barack Obama was tired of sending his army to fight Wars in the middle.
East.
So instead of making big military moves, he chose to call the guys at Langley.
That's how the CIA created the timber second war program to this day.
This program remains classified. So there is very little information about it.
But what little we do know is that the CIA has been buying weapons on the black
market Balkans.
And what kind of weapons,
AK 40 sevens nightmares and goggles and grenade launchers.
These weapons were used to are many of the groups fighting. Alison,
on the other hand, the CIA was training these folks.
Yes, I know what you're thinking. And you're right.
Many of these groups were organizations of how should we put this organizations
of the dubious?
Stancher it's still not clear who received these weapons and training from the
CIA,
but it will not be the first time the United States ends up giving weapons to
those who will later on. Okay.
Enemies.
As soon as Donald Trump set foot in the white house,
the timber second more program was canceled overnight.
Tens of thousands of Syrian gorillas with first class,
military training were left without us support. This is where Turkey comes in.
This is who the Syrian national army was born.
A group of mercenaries in the service of Turkey.
Each one charges between $1,502,000 a month and has the right to apply for
Turkish citizens.
Sure.
Remember I told you that the army of Azerbaijan is not as well trained as that
of Armenia. Well, no Turkey has been able to solve this problem.
It is estimated that between 701,000 Syrian mercenaries under contract to
Turkey, I've been fighting in the war and Nagorno-Karabakh of course,
everyone denies all these accusations, but news headlines like this,
we speak for themselves.
No goal, no Karabakh at least three.
Syrian fighters killed. Of course.
Some might say that these Syrian fighters were just passing by and said,
come on, let's get involved in a war in a country that we don't know.
Let's go fight over there and see what happens.
But it seems more reasonable to think that Turkey has paid them to fight their
war. So we have Azerbaijan on the one hand,
which has four times the money than Armenia,
large gas reserves and the unconditional support.
Turkey.
So the question now is who is supporting Armenia.
And for the time being the answer is no one,
one of his possible allies would be around. But for the moment,
Iran has limited itself to securing its border by placing 200 times along the
frontier to prevent the war from spilling over to their site,
Russia as a traditional ally of Armenia. In fact,
as a military based in the city of camaraderie with more than 3000 soldiers,
We're over Armenia is a member of the collective security treaty organization,
which is something like the Russian NATO and principle.
If Azerbaijan were to attack Armenia,
Russia would be obliged to come to its defense,
but don't forget that Nagorno-Karabakh is officially part of Azerbaijani
territory. Technically Azerbaijan has not invaded any country.
It is simply trying to regain a territory that belongs to.
And now you're probably thinking since when is Russia a country that respects
international law? Is it not in Putin's interest to control the caucuses,
of course, as, but for several years now,
Moscow and Bakula have been cultivating good relations.
We explained it to you on visual politic two years ago,
Russia and Azerbaijan need each other to be able to send their guests to Europe.
What's more, Russia has serious problems in the caucuses regions,
such as Chechnya and Dagestan are possible focuses of Islamic terrorism.
The last thing most school wants is to have Islamic attacks on its own
territory. If all of a sudden Russia were to attack Azerbaijan,
which is a Muslim country back who could very well straight back.
The truth is that the European union needs gas from Azerbaijan to reduce its
dependence on Russia. In other words,
Turkey is the only power that wants to enter this conflict.
And all of this explains Moscow's interest and trying to negotiate a ceasefire
as soon as possible.
[Inaudible].
Armenia and Azerbaijan agree ceasefire.
However,
this ceasefire has been agreed on without Turkey and air one has already said
that it's just a truce I Teresa Armenia to withdraw all of its troops from
Nagorno-Karabakh new concessions. So hours after the ceasefire was approved,
the Azerbaijani guns again, fired missiles. I should a panic.
So no, the question is over to you.
Do you think Russia or NATO will end up getting involved in this conflict? Well,
we end up seeing the definitive end of this war with a peace agreement.
More importantly. What do you think about Turkey's role in this conflict?
To what extent are they responsible for what is happening in the granola counter
back? We'll leave your answers in the comments and as always.
I'll see you next time.